did you know that a whale has this extra
emotional core that we've
heard about now with the film i had
never heard that before were you aware
of that when you began working
i did not know anything about these
animals in their natural habitat before
i started working at sea world
i only really learned about about their
natural history and about what they're
really like in the wild
after um actually recently in the past
three years i've learned about killer
whales but i didn't really know much
about
uh their anything about them when i was
working there other than how to train
them
yeah you know i i i same thing i
i was not aware um of those especially
aspects of neuroanatomy that we've
learned over the last couple of years
um had no idea i think the one thing
that i was aware of when i started there
was about their social connectedness
though and the fact that they stayed
together in their family units
throughout their lives
you